music you carry it with you in a tune
it's a different part of the brain I
think and it uh look at it sticks with
you for years and years powerful
78 years old
Jeff's Family shared the news of his
death in a statement on Instagram
revealing he died peacefully on Tuesday
after suddenly Contracting bacterial
meningitis
quote his family asked for privacy while
they process this tremendous loss
foreign
death comes just months after he toured
Europe with Johnny Depp the two began
collaborating on music in 2020. and
there was a knock at the door and there
was somebody saying Johnny Depp would
like to meet you know fine okay I didn't
really know him I didn't I knew that it
was Jack Sparrow but I'd never seen
anything fell he was just like a brother
straight away fast forward to 2021
Johnny and Jeff released a joint album
together titled 18.
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
when he joined the Yardbirds in 1965
after replacing Eric Clapton after
leaving the band he formed the Jeff Beck
Group which was fronted by Rod Stewart
for a brief time
again
we just
[Music]
his voice has changed a little bit since
back then you know but when I first
heard that you I mean you didn't need to
really be a musical expert to realize
the hairy throat of this you know rare
rare quality and I love I love the way
he's saying it was very flattered when
he joined my band
over his career Jeff became a two-time
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame in Duck tea
and eight-time Grammy winner he's also
nominated for two awards at this year's
upcoming ceremony for his work with Ozzy
Osbourne
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jeff is survived by his wife Sandra Beck
[Music]